yo let me ask you a question mike yeah
let me ask you a question
uh first of all it's a nice shirt you
got on there
shout out that's nice
um thank you
nuggets we haven't talked about the
nuggets and lakers
and yeah
i i know you were you were all in on the
nuggets when they beat the clippers in
game seven shut them down
wasn't even a competitive game in the
last three four minutes
how do you feel about the lakers
going into this series opener tonight uh
and how do you feel about the nuggets
matched up with the lakers
look man i i said this jokingly the
other day um i love to see us uh
simulate so we were talking about madden
a minute ago i love to simulate to game
five i love i i want this to be 3-1
let's start this series 3-1 and then see
what happens since the nuggets seem to
be so comfortable coming back from 3-1
deficits i'd love to see uh you know
what would happen at that point so
that's a series kind of going back to
how we started the show talking about
whether the eastern conference finals
were over
that's a series that
whether it's 2-0 3-1
i think it's safe to say we're in for a
long one you know the nuggets belong
here they present a lot of problems
for for defenses
uh they play with a lot of confidence
they're like as look at it as jamal
murray said as jo as jamal murray said
at the end of game seven the lakers got
to worry about us too
yeah you about to get married
i'm gonna stop now cause i wanna hear
this do you put me in a bad mood again
yeah yeah i know i wanna hit my man uh
i'm gonna hit my man on the three-way
pretty soon though we hit my man gary
washburn see what he have to say about
it
you cool with washburn right we can have
a three-way conversation with yeah yeah
of course of course yeah all right but
i don't think it's gonna be a long
series and i thought that i thought that
i was looking at the nuggets and
clippers and stuff let's define long
first let's define long first what do
you mean was i got six i think six is
long i defined six okay six it's a hard
six
hard six four two lakers hard six is
what i'm talking about probably five
they're probably five and i'm gonna tell
you why i'm gonna tell you why so lebron
james did not win the mvp i don't think
he should have i think giannis i'm
giving giannis his respect back to back
mvps
but lebron james
another
amazing season at the age of 35. mike
i feel like i feel like he's getting
smarter like he's like i'm not sure it's
the best it's not the best basketball of
his career the assists are high i've
seen him have better statistical seasons
but he just he just knows what he wants
to do he's not trying to do too much got
the answer to the test yeah yeah yeah
he's not trying to uh take over a game
too early if it's there for him he'll
take it
those 10 assists
suggest that he he knows how to give it
up too now he's giving you scoring
giving 25 a game and 10 assists
but i'm just looking at it this way mike
you realize
that lebron james
never i know the fact i know your fact
checking army is gonna be out there
saying oh i didn't caught him on this
one
he's lying now he forgot something you
know lebron james has never played with
a first-team all-nba play teammate until
this year until one of my favorite guys
in the world anthony davis
uh joined them
i mean look that's
yeah what go ahead
he's never done oh no no i'm gonna i'm
gonna let you live i'm gonna let you
live i'm gonna let you live i'm i'm not
i'm not gonna live up here
no no i'm not go i'm not gonna blow up
your spot never blow up your smile you
got enough you got enough grief for
patty labelle i'm not gonna expose how
you really feel about anthony davis i'm
i'm not gonna tell you what guys
friendship said friend of the show about
anthony davis i'm not gonna i'm shocking
anthony davis
i'm not going to share private
conversations i'm going to keep what
happens in the locker room in the locker
room go ahead i'm sorry i just want to i
want to add one more thing about anthony
davis let me just add this real quick
it's a shame they never gave him the
support he
[Laughter]
a straight face you can't even say it
with a straight face
you can't even say it with a string
man go ahead go ahead go ahead and lie
lie it's a shame this is life got the
support
he deserved in new orleans you know he
made the playoffs twice in seven years
there and if he had better support man
you know maybe he could have gotten a
four out of seven or something like that
but he this is you could say
he's never had this much talent around
him at the elite at the elite level
now he's had talented teams but never a
first-team all-nba player alongside him
so i just can't imagine
mike i can't imagine lebron james at
this age with his intelligence with the
talent around him
with his focus i can't imagine a dimmer
nuggets coming in and taking him to a
long series can't see it let's let's
just be let's just be fair not in you're
not being inaccurate it's not a fact
check but let's just be fair okay
you pointed out yesterday how rare it is
for two teammates to make first team
all-nba and number five
okay so let's not act like lebron this
is not an anti-lebron statement this is
just an interest of accuracy let's not
act like lebron has never had great
teammates around him yes
dwyane wade
may not have been
first team all-nba
while he was with lebron experience but
he was still dwyane wade yeah you know
or whether it or kyrie irving may not
have been made out of been first team
all nba
but nonetheless he was still
with lebron james so it's one of those
like yeah he never had a first-team
all-nba teammate well a lot of people
have never had first-team all-nba
teammates like that's not okay it's only
five and okay that's a that's a that's a
fair you know clarific uh clarification
yeah yeah yeah
i'm trying to be that guy i'm just
saying i don't want that guy
because you may you may be that guy
anyway that's all right be that guy but
i will say
in most arguments about greatness
we're talking about very slight grades
aren't we i mean it's it's like these
minuscule shades of who who's in your
top five or your top ten at the end of
the argument you're still talking about
10 fantastic players so to help you
separate it you got to just make these
little distinctions okay right well
never been a first-team all-nba guy
alongside lebron i understand it anthony
davis
uh with all respect to those guys that
you mentioned
my favorite player in the nba anthony
davis
is much more accomplished than
much more you know he just keeps laying
away he just keeps going up one minute
is like oh i love anthony davis
davis nice
i know now i'm hating on it oh man this
this narrative man it's just you keep
you crafting it on the spot like you you
put but honestly speaking anthony davis
as brilliant as lebron is and you're
right i mean you know he's gotten
smarter without losing any of the you
know the physical capabilities he hasn't
lost the step he's not smarter to
compensate for anything and it's not
just that he's smarter before i get to
the point about this series i'll throw
some more i'll give lebron more flowers
shall we say
it's not just smarter
i think it's that
he's come he's continued
to come into himself
as a whole person
i think everything he does off the court
fuels
his comfort on the court i think
he just learned not only to be more and
more comfortable
with his game and with who he is and
with and understand how to wield his
power in the most effective way i think
he just became more comfortable as time
went on it's not just that he's in the
spotlight he controls the spotlight you
know like he he controls the brightness
of the spotlight and is it is more than
comfortable stepping to the microphone
more than comfortable being the leader
asserting control not just of
you know the locker room
but any room that he steps into and any
conversation that he's a part of you
know at one point he was like i love to
see a conversation between him and odell
about listening to the critics at one
point it did get in his head at one
point he was in his own head now that
he's accomplished all he's accomplished
and gotten over that hump several times
he the pressure that he's feeling right
now if he does feel any pressure is not
about his legacy his leg is he's secure
he's driving about something greater
he's drink he's driven by a a larger
purpose it's not about him chasing
michael jordan anymore he's he's done
chasing michael jordan he's his own
legend
that's right two quick things i hit you
with two quick things one and we had
this conversation earlier earlier this
week you know
not not during brother from another but
brother from another after dark when we
just talked on the phone when i said you
go back and listen to lebron james
interviews from when he was 18 or 19
years old
it's there like the the structure of the
house is there
he didn't necessarily have the language
that he has now but you can see like the
seed already in place and to your point
yes it's almost like this blossoming of
lebron james now and i can see how that
adds to it another quick uh quick thing
mike uh i'm such a nerd for so many
reasons number 750 reason number 750 i'm
a nerd i went back and i listened to
lebron james's
uh parade speech where he's going around
saying something about each in cleveland
after they came back against the
warriors and he's going around he's
saying something positive about each
teammate each member of the organization